E aí
[Música]
nem toda criança tem um super-herói
preferido a minha sobrinha neta por
exemplo adora mulher-maravilha a super
heroína favorita dela é uma mulher forte
Imbatível capaz de vencer todas as
adversidades
quem nunca conheceu uma criança que quer
crescer para ser como o homem-aranha
mulher-gato ou super-homem Pois é
durante muitos anos eu fui chamada de
heroína também como todos esses nomes se
a Rosana criança soubesse disso tem
certeza que acharia muito legal mas a
realidade é um pouco diferente você já
sentiram o peso EA responsabilidade
de serem considerados exemplos de vida o
modelo de superação ou até motivos de
inspiração para alguém não pois eu já
senti e posso dizer que não é nada leve
por volta de um ano de idade Olá meus
pais conheceram o moço do realejo e
pagar ou para o passarinho tirar o papel
que traria prevista toda minha sorte
para os mais jovens realejo é o carrinho
que toca música que tem um passarinho
que tira papéis da Sorte em uma caixinha
saíram só coisas boas previstas daquele
papelzinho eu seria uma pessoa muito
inteligente bonita saudável enfia uma
pessoa de muito sucesso
havia números previstos para a loteria
bem eu nunca ganhei na loteria mas com
alguma frequência me vejo pensando nos
outros itens daquele papel eu tenho
certeza que meus pais duvidaram se eu
seria mesmo tudo aquilo que estava
escrito ali quando poucos meses depois
daquele encontro com o realejo eu me vi
totalmente
paralisada em uma cama com febre
altíssima
é morta durante mais de 40 dias até que
o vírus da pólio fosse embora e deixar
se o seu estrago já era Todas aquelas
qualidades não poderiam coexistir com a
deficiência e assim eu cresci sempre
ouvindo que apesar da minha doença eu
teria que ser uma menina muito estudiosa
muito inteligente e feliz ao 7 anos fui
matriculada em um colégio de freiras
caríssimo só para meninas meu pai se
revirava como por dia para pagar as
mensalidades sem saber que eu era
extremamente infeliz daquele colégio
porque as freiras tinham tanto medo de
eu me machucar que me proibiu de ir para
o recreio com as outras meninas iam
ficava sozinha merendando dentro de sala
de aula o resultado Eu quase não tinha
amiguinhas mas felizmente meu médico na
ocasião e ainda eficiente vítima de
pólio aconselhou minha mãe a me tirar
daquele colégio e me matricular em uma
escola pública regular onde eu ia para o
recreio brincavam de pega-pega era
empurrada cair e me levantava com vivia
com a falta de acessibilidade e era
muito feliz foi na adolescência que
comecei a perceber e entender uma certa
diferença no tratamento que eu recebia
por parte das pessoas a maioria me
tratava muito bem era sempre o a chuva
de elogios desnecessários que o de
testava porque sabia não merecemos ao
mesmo tempo uma discriminação disfarçada
aos poucos todas as minhas amigas foram
arrumando os namorados e paqueras e a
história se repetirá com todas menos
comigo foi assim que eu descobri eu era
diferente das outras meninas por volta
dos dezoito o anos eu já me reconheci
uma pessoa com deficiência e não a
pessoa doente como me fizeram acreditar
mas apesar de já me reconhecer
deficiente eu nunca havia sido tratada
como tal pelo contrário nem meu maior
ponto de apoio a minha família me via
assim eu era tratada por todos como uma
jovem que tinha uma doença incurável e
eu não esculpo até mesmo porque naquela
época havia muita falta de informação
sobre o tema ninguém sabia nada de nada
veja o que estamos falando dos anos
setenta e seis a 79 não sei falar em
deficiência não se viam deficientes
éramos todos doentes
conviver e ver pessoas com deficiência
foi fundamental para que eu me
reconhecesse fui apresentado a um grupo
de jovens deficientes que fazia
tratamento no e para piar a todos
paraplégicos e tetraplégicos por
acidentes de carro armas de fogo e
outros motivos que fundaram a Associação
Mineira de paraplégicos
ali eu percebi que eu não tinha culpa de
nada e que a sociedade é que estava em
dívida comigo que meus direitos tinham
que ser reconhecidos e respeitados assim
como os direitos do meu vizinho sem
deficiência ali eu vi conhecia aprende
os conceitos de igualdade diferença e
entende que eu era diferente na medida
das minhas necessidades específicas as
quais deveriam ser respeitadas e
reconhecidas
e não que eu deveria ter tratamento
diferenciado ou ser uma pessoa com
deficiência foi ali que eu entendi que
aquela responsabilidade e o peso que
estavam sobre os meus ombros de ter que
Sul a minha deficiência vez Erlene não
eram meus eu não queria ser exemplo de
vida para ninguém e viver a minha vida
normalmente não era motivo para me
chamarem de heroína bom o tempo passou e
muita coisa mudou mudou por conta dessa
militância na qual eu me iniciei e junto
com pessoas importantíssimas para o
processo
desenvolvemos uma luta que teve batalhas
ferrenhas a maioria das quais a gente
ganhou luta essa que ainda Percy mas há
uma batalha nessa guerra que nós ainda
precisaremos Vencer é o preconceito da
sociedade em relação às pessoas com
deficiências Sem dúvida hoje esse
preconceito se apresenta de uma forma
mais velada e ganhou o nome bonito e
moderno de capacitismo trata-se de um
preconceito estrutural que como é a
mania corrói a sociedade e tenta nos
diminuir tenta nos invisibilizar tenta
nos transformar em objetos para remissão
de suas culpas fraqueza sem medo na
verdade fomos de certa forma enganado
nos Venderam a ideia de que a
deficiência é uma coisa ruim um castigo
de Deus uma punição para sua família e
não apenas uma adversidade em nossas
vidas focaram em nos ensinar a lamentar
as nossas deficiências mas não nos
ensinaram que a adversidade não é um
obstáculo para que continuemos a viver a
nossa vida pensa o que por sermos
capazes de viver com as nossas
deficiências somos seres excepcionais
o E durante muito tempo nosso propagamos
ainda mais essa falácia e fortalecemos
esse conceito de inspiração veio porque
a mídia contribuiu de forma especial
para isso você já deve ter visto por aí
dezenas de imagens e vídeos tais como um
homem sem as pernas trabalhando de
pedreiro carregando a lata de massa com
a legenda Você ainda tem motivos para
reclamar ou uma jovem senhora sem os
braços cozinhando com os pés e trocando
fralda de seu filho e a legenda a única
deficiência não tentar ou cadeirante no
topo da montanha com os braços abertos a
deficiência não é obstáculo para o
sucesso eu chamo de falsa e inspiração
Por que essas imagens o vírus
objetificam um grupo de pessoas em favor
de outro grupo e nesse caso as pessoas
com deficiência o sendo transformadas em
objetos em favor das pessoas sem
deficiência essas imagens em inspiram e
motivam você leva o você a pensar que
por mais que a sua vida esteja ruim
ainda poderia ser pior se você fosse um
ou uma de nós pessoas com deficiência eu
já perdi a conta do número de pessoas
que vieram me dizer que me admiram que
admiram a minha coragem que eu sou uma
inspiração para elas apenas pelo fato de
eu viver com a minha deficiência ou seja
Elas estavam me parabenizando pelo fato
de eu acordar todos os dias eu estudar
ou de ser uma dona de casa e trabalhar
como qualquer outra pessoa e talvez você
ainda não tenha entendido o problema em
nos parabenizar por fazermos
absolutamente o que todo mundo faz
quando as nossas de fiz e são empregadas
por uma ótica de lamentação ou
idealização todas as nossas
potencialidades habilidades e
conhecimentos são reduzidos a esse único
espaço as pessoas com deficiência deixam
de ser vistas como pessoas sensuais
excelentes profissionais ou líderes em
nossa sociedade ao sermos colocados em
pedestais que devem inspirar e motivar
todas essas outras características são
negadas para nós mas todos esses Passos
precisam ser reivindicados foi com a
minha deficiência que eu me tornei
atleta paralímpica integrando a primeira
equipe Brasileira Feminina no basquete
Sobre Rodas nas paralimpíadas de
atlanta-96 e não foi apenas isso também
conquistei um trabalho que me inspirava
e encontrei o amor da minha vida ele
também era um atleta é o primeiro
cadeirante a completar a volta da
Pampulha vencendo muitos corredores sem
deficiência nos casamos vivemos 20 anos
juntos e tivemos dois filhos até que o
infarto fulminante me lembrou aquela
parte do discurso Até que a morte nos
separe
acredito que esse capacitismo praticado
todos os dias é uma herança social e
como tal muito difícil de ser extirpado
porque a mesma sociedade que nos elogia
aí nos a Cloud é a mesma que nos nego
exercício da nossa cidadania dos nossos
direitos básicos como educação inclusiva
saúde lazer trabalho acessibilidade nos
pega respeito nos priva de estarmos
presentes nos Espaços comuns é a mesma
sociedade que se orgulha em fazer por
nós se orgulha e nos doar migalhas de
cidadania e para se auto exaltarem é
preciso que entendam de uma vez por
todas que já se foi o tempo que era uns
apenas objetos de políticas
assistencialistas
para justificar a atuação das
primeiras-damas Hoje queremos ocupar
espaços de direito queremos exercer
cargos de liderança nas empresas nos
governos nos espaços de políticas
Queremos ser protagonistas da nossa
história
defendemos e acreditamos no lema nada
sobre nós sem nós a verdade é que quando
analisamos as bases da nossa sociedade
todo discurso de inclusão pareces vai
ficar nítido que ainda existem muitas
batalhas a serem travadas não podemos
sonhar com políticas públicas mais
inclusivas se pessoas com deficiência
não estiverem inseridas na formulação e
implementação e dessas mesmas políticas
segundo pesquisa realizada pela empresa
Catho em parceria com a consultoria
Santo caus menos de 10 porcento dos
profissionais com deficiência ocupam
cargos de liderança nessas empresas onde
trabalham enquanto não estivermos das
Mesas onde as decisões são tomadas as
nossas necessidades e vozes continuarão
sendo silenciados por mais de 20 anos
ocupei cargos no governo de Minas na
Secretaria de Desenvolvimento Social
secretaria de esportes Secretaria de
Trabalho não foram poucas as vezes em
que eu era a única pessoa com
deficiência presente e a minha presença
nesses locais deixou um legado
importante que foi o entendimento de que
as políticas públicas que ali foram
implantadas foram muito mais eficientes
e eram muito mais credibilidade porque
havia alguém com deficiência à frente
por exemplo hoje temos implantados na
secretaria de esportes de Minas Gerais
vários programas cujo o resultado foi a
presença de vários atletas mineiros
medalhistas das paralimpíadas de toca
quando Assumimos esse lugar de
protagonismo ajudamos a quebrar os
paradigmas de que as pessoas com
deficiência não são capazes não estão
Preparadas é que para além de objetos de
inspiração para além de sermos exemplos
de vida e superação queremos viver em
uma sociedade transformada Eu Sei Que Eu
Não verei mas meus netos Talvez possa
ver os seus netos poderão ver queremos
viver em uma sociedade diversa plural
possível onde nós pessoas com deficiên
que sejamos vistos não por nossas
deficiências mas antes de tudo pelo
nosso trabalho e Pelas nossas conquistas
eu Rosana Bastos quero ser elogiada ao
final dessa fala pelo conteúdo da mesma
pela minha apresentação e não por ser
uma mulher com deficiência que teve
coragem aí para chegar até aqui na
próxima vez que me chamarem de heroína
quero que seja porque conquistei meus
objetivos ou para salvar alguém mas não
por dirigir um carro atravessar a rua
sozinha ou exercer a minha liberdade e
agora eu pergunto a vocês Será que o
passarinho do realejo acertou muito
obrigada e
E aí